どうもみなさんこんにちははじめんです
あっつい入ったわけで皆さんこのくそ暑い夏の日
どのようにお過ごしでしょうか問題がというと逆にも育てるほうが間違いなんじゃねっ
て暮らし錯覚するぐらい熱いんですけど皆さん暑さ対策
どうされていますでしょうか特に男子女子はいろいろ熱いと思うんですけど
方とか出したりスカートとかでを吸う吸うできると思うんですけども男はで
いたって t シャツなんですよねこういうなんかアウトプットも切れると思うんです
けど僕にはそんな勇気がないか食ってるないですなんで基本的に t シャツとかまぁ
長ズボンとか半ズボンまでなかなか攻めてきにくいから出ると思うんで乙女とは結構夏
ねあついーと思うんですよ
もちろん女性もですけど sonar 生なかどのように熱をカバーしていくかといい
ますと
服の色色とか素材だと思うんだ
です簡単な話からさせていただきますと黒い服二枚服っていうのは基本的に遠赤外線
効果で別を吸収しやすいので熱くなってしまいますね追求しないが熱くなっちゃったね
ほんとはね黒い服ってあんまりな強くないんですよ
外出るとき逆に白い服は a 席が平行板が薄いので熱の吸収が弱いまで基本的に夏は
みんなから白いきた方が涼しいのかもしれ
いませんねダガーとか私は思ったら私怒ってしまってもっともっと涼しく夏を過ごす
方法はないかと思った時に昔理科の授業で習ったんですよ黒いものは体温低いを吸収し
て熱くなりやすい白いのは太陽の光をお腹弾いで
が大丈夫で鏡金属みたい中に入ってこう
光を当てると話しするじゃないですか高つまりですよ
太陽の光もその金属的なあーてカレーが雪だったら弾くんですよ光を反射して多くの
みたいに急所を押し出してしっかり見たい何かそんな中
くれてなんないしたんだ金属メタルで服を作ったら一番通信じゃねーかということで
今回缶バッジ所何来た僕は干ばつに1400を準備しました
したが分かんないですけどこんなにの缶バッジを鼻につけて街を歩いたらいいよという
概念がない金属グループ日本の針だけ飛び出てるの声色で概念がないので全ての熱を
遮断し太陽光弾く訂單字がすべての太陽光外れた時
ターン涼しいんですよとらずにカン抹茶をつけてすべての太陽光遮断し阪神弾き
[音楽]
ブーブそう
スレ
[音楽]
プー台中けどお待たせしました全身がんばっつりなってしまいました
サッと感じた感じすごい多いですからただメンダーアベンジャーズみたいでちょっと
かっこいいです後音がうるさい
やばい者様からいいんだけど大事なのはここからですこれで外に行って太陽の光を浴び
形熱いのか暑くないか
そこが大事なポイントなので早速所
に行ってみようと思いますしちゃいますっ
おすすめあっと思っています
熱くなって欲しいない
注目度がやばすぎるますよまあそうなってます何でもやった対策してるだけなのに
マジヤバイなと比べ工藤が同じ
そんな変化なカレーていた感触
少ないと思ったよりおっ太陽的なあったら本当に感じないった家族がめっちゃさだん
だろうねばちゃんとしてるよこれ取れちゃう
浮かべるじゃないけどめっちゃくそするは恋カフェや悪目立ちするなぁこれ
涼しいですよあの採用を反射するんでああ
俺が理論と一番涼しかも知れています
そしてねー
開いてないみんなまでしてくれ
あったからいいわけです
レッサーオサレな人にはオサレに見えるらしいのです
赤岳金はなるでしょうねみんなチカーナ3回
遠く熱いすいやー熱くないまず分
あれとって
ございます
話ではない
[音楽]
me
teame
うううう
car
ブルーあっ
me
こちらするはずです
金融 h
まぁ結果
くそだという溝付きませんやとして